on the agenda we had a potential
collective boycott of the 1968 olympics
uh we educated ourselves as to why we
thought it was necessary to make a
statement such as a boycott
we attempted to educate as best we could
the young athletes my teammates
as to why we felt that they should bite
in or buy into this particular boycott
but many of them felt like hey they've
trained all their lives you know they
promise their kids they cherished the
community that they would go to the
games and win
win a medal uh we didn't have the right
to
dictate to them and tell them that
absolutely you must boycott these games
when they took the vote decided to go so
be it but yet and still i felt it was
still
very necessary to make a statement
a humane statement about the ills of
society that affected blacks and people
of color
not just in the united states but
throughout the world
so yeah i'm very i'm very interested in
hearing it it was a
shoeless protest wasn't it and you
talked to me i believe you had left your
uh black gloves in the or gloves in the
olympic village so you had to to borrow
one
that's nonsense that's nonsense it was
only one set of gloves from the start
uh you know along the way people would
do a lot of additives
into it like as if though they were
there they they dictate what was going
on but that's that's total uh nonsense
what effect did it have i mean it was uh
widely perceived you were ostracized
weren't you expelled
uh they did that but that was the powers
to be once again
trying to restrict individuals of color
from making a statement you know i
didn't get on the victory stand and pull
my pants down the moon society i didn't
give the finger
and discuss about what was happening i
think what i did was something that was
very dignified something was very
necessary and something that was very
educational oh was it
a trailblazing moment for what was to
come
well the trailblazing moment in the
olympic games that's for sure
but it's not a trailblazing moment in in
regards to
trying to fight for equality and justice
what can be done now we heard that the
olympic
international olympic committee have
allowed protests now haven't they
let's uh spring forward to now but but
not on the podium is that a
disappointment to you
well it is really uh
no change of the rule i mean they're
just trying to put a band-aid on it and
give me the impression that they made a
change but they didn't make any
significant change
uh you know like uh if if i'm gonna
protest i'm gonna go into london bridge
and protest i'm not gonna go
beneath the bridge underneath the bridge
behind the bridge
i'm going to be on the bridge to make
that statement why because i'm trying to
reach as many
people as i possibly can they can
restrict you
and add or take away when you do
something on the side
that they're going to film they can edit
but when it's live
and living color they cannot edit
because they're spontaneous they have to
respond to what they're seeing right
before the eyes
what kind of protests will you expect
this time
then to to see
well i'm sure every individual that
decides to make some sort of statement
i'm sure would be just as dignified as
the statement that was made in 68
however i don't know what particular uh
protests they will make other than the
fact that i would say that each
individual has to
check his moral compass if morally you
think something is wrong and you think
you can be a catalyst to bring attention
to it
to make things better you have that
right no one on this earth has the right
to tell you that you don't have that
right
the powers to be in the universe the
gods of the world
they're the ones that can dictate as to
whether you have a right to make a
statement
or not not no one that's hosting the
olympic games
how much has changed in the fight
against
racial injustice over the past five
decades john
well i would think that more people have
blind they have taken the blinders off i
think more people can think clearly
for themselves you know years ago you
know 50
53 years ago many individuals were led
by headlines in the newspaper
they were hit led by commentary from the
news media now today with the
internet the way it is individuals can
see things spontaneously and they can
digest it
and make a decision as to whether it was
right or wrong up or down for themselves
now
talk about these carry on
i was going to say there's far more many
people as young individuals
in terms of athletes starting to realize
who they are
what their worth is and how many people
they can communicate to
to realize uh that we all have this
problem when we all
have to come together to try and solve
this this issue called race
relations do you think people are
listened to
more than perhaps than they were in 1968
i believe many people were listening now
i think many people are
far more uh clear point in their minds
now
i think they have a new paradigm today
than they had back
53 years ago and at the same time the
athletes are saying
there's no turning back we will never go
back to what it once was prior to 1968.
and i might ask you a question as a
journalist the question for you is
when was the rule 50 established was
established when
when the nazis got in the stands in in
berlin in 1936
and gave the house sign with swat
stickers running up and down the stadium
i don't recall reading anything about
them establishing rule 50 from that
but rule 50 came about very strongly
after we
made a statement in 1968 two young
individual black men
with the support of a young individual
white man
and uh very very quickly uh in one
sentence dina asha smith she's taking
this stand people should have the right
to protest she says
absolutely she's absolutely correct and
i have
a hero in england that i'm so proud of
her and i support her in every
any way i can because there's a young
lady that realized
that she is a beacon for society and she
can make a statement to have
other people begin to think for
themselves as to whether
it's necessary for individuals to step
up in the most critical time of their
lives to make a statement for the better
part of the world